I've been using a whole homemade copper strap on my foot for grounding.
Will I sleep?
Should wall?
I think wall I sleep.
I think that's what you meant.
I'm using a homemade copper strap on my foot for grounding while I sleep.
Should I stop?
I know you didn't like copper and some of the things I was taking before.
So no, a copper strap on your foot to a grounding to a ground in the wall that's grounded to your electrical that's grounded to the ground is just fine.
You're not going to absorb any copper.
You're very little copper through your skin, so you're fine with that.
You could keep doing that.
Why shouldn't a person who has cancer be consuming a lot of copper?
I shouldn't the person with cancer be using copper pans?
Why shouldn't the person with cancer be taking supplements with copper?
Because copper is good for you, right?
You need copper.
Well, first of all, copper is good for you.
What does copper do?
It excites growth.
So why does the cancer patient want to be careful about a copper they're exposed to?
Because you don't want to be excited growth.
So therefore I don't like a person to have a lot of copper in your supplements.
So obviously a whole food supplement might have a little copper because it's in the food that you're eating.
You're getting copper in your food that you're eating.
That's just fine.
The idea of person using copper pans or copper cups.
I've seen Instagram videos where people are saying,
oh, I use a copper copper because copper is so good for you.
It's just idiotic because that's elemental copper.
That's not how you're supposed to eat your copper.
We're going to chew on a piece of copper.
I think that's good for you.
No, copper is in the soil and then plants take copper, bond it to a double bond glycine atom.
And then we eat the plant.
We don't eat elemental copper.
It's like iron people could go, well, I use an iron pan to cook with because iron is good.
Because iron is good for us.
No, no, that's not how you get your iron.
It's not wrong with using an iron pan.
But that's not how you would get your iron.
You don't suck on a piece of iron to get your iron.
That's elemental iron.
You can't absorb that.
It's probably going to cause constipation issues and such.
You get iron through your food.
And if you're going to take an iron supplement because you have low iron or iron deficiency anemia,
you would take an iron supplement that's in the that's in the form that you would get it in food.
Not in by the piece of iron.
So it's not a nonsense out there.
So just be careful of that.
But using a copper strap on your foot, there's no problem with that.
You're not absorbing any of that copper.
And copper is a good conductor of electricity.
So it's a good way for you to ground.